Marvel Studios has been under a
microscope Lately by not only the fans
but now the industry major Outlets are
writing pieces about Marvel Studios
asking the question are they done
insiders are writing massive books about
what is happening at Marvel Studios
right now and what their endgame plan is
and while Marvel Studios may not be
performing at the same capacity that it
was prior to phase 4 of the MCU I still
believe that Marvel Studios can make
really great movies and can turn the MCU
around and make the last half of the
Multiverse Saga and the beginning of the
mutant Saga amazing and it looks like
Marvel Studios has put things in plan to
make sure that happens starting with
getting Robert Downey Jr and Chris Evans
to return what is going on everybody
welcome back to the cosmic wonder I'm
Warren Thompson and you probably have
heard all of the news going around
lately with the Variety article with the
new book MCU the reign of Marvel Studios
plus we've been talking about it on the
channel for a little bit Marvel Studios
might be considering doing a reboot of
the MCU after Secret Wars in fact it
sounds like they're pretty much going to
do it although it's going to be a soft
reboot not a hard reboot they're not
just going to start over a part of the
current universe that our main MCU is in
right now will still remain however with
the premise of the Multiverse and
Avengers Secret Wars it opens up the
possibility to essentially do anything
and there are two parts to this when it
comes to before Secret Wars and after
Secret Wars specifically in regards to
Robert Dy Junior returning and Chris
Evans returning as well plus not to
mention somebody like Scarlett Johansson
also returning we'll break down
everything you need to know in this
video and quick reminder if you want a
chance to win a PS5 and Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items all you have to do is subscribe to
the channel and leave a comment on our
videos this automatically enters you in
our giveaway we do one every single
month the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick one winner at the end of
each month so according to The Insider
my time to shine Hello both Robert
Downey Jr and Chris Evans have already
agreed to return to the MCU now I
mentioned that there were two parts to
this this is going to be part one the
two of them returning for Avengers
Secret Wars this is something that just
makes sense this is something that we've
been talking about since we found out
the whole plot for this Saga is the
Multiverse Saga and it's all leading up
to aveng your secret Wars since we found
that out and probably even before we've
been speaking about this why because it
just makes sense it would make sense one
to satisfy the fans but two story-wise
it would also make a lot of sense if
you're going to have a movie that shows
us variance from a lot of different
universes and have the Multiverse come
together at the end to fight on one
giant king Army of variants it would
make sense that we would see some OG
Avengers variants some of the same
character played by the same person for
example Iron Man played by Robert Downey
Jr Chris Evans playing Captain America
again but then you could have some
different variants like Chris Evans
playing the Human Torch or John krinski
playing Captain America America because
he auditioned for that role you could
even have Loki being a variant of Thor
since he auditioned to Play Thor
originally as well this is stuff we've
been talking about for a while it just
makes sense to do and in the report my
time to shine hello tweeted sources
confirmed that Chris Evans also agreed
to come back for Avengers Secret Wars
however in her original tweet about
Robert Downey Jr she just simply said
Robert Downey Jr agreed to come back now
this brings us to part two after
Avengers Secret Wars and it also comes
with a really big question that I'll ask
after we explain this but part two is
Robert dowy Jr and Chris Evans remaining
in the MCU as a part of the main
Universe after Secret Wars remaining in
the MCU after the reboot now if you've
been watching our podcast you know that
me and law have been talking about the
possibility of after the reboot these
characters coming back for a while now
that was us just trying to predict
things and us being fans but then the
book MCU the reign of Marvel Studios
came out with a lot of inside
information about Marvel and they stated
that Marvel Studios is considering
bringing them back for the soft reboot
and then to top it all off a lot of
people saw that Variety article talking
about them coming back and if you didn't
here is the title chis is at Marvel
Jonathan Major's backup plans the
Marvel's re-shoot Reviving original
Avengers and more issues revealed so now
a lot of people are talking about Marvel
Studios having plans to revive the
original Avengers we are talking about
Iron Man Captain America and Natasha
Romanov AKA Black Widow now this is
coming at a time where as variety puts
it there is a crisis at Marvel and
whether you think it's a major crisis at
Marvel Studios right now or not we do
know that Marvel Studios is definitely
changing their plans and coming up with
new plans they were recently on their
Retreat and variety states that normally
when they go for this Retreat everybody
is very happy very confident even cocky
but this time it was full with angst
because they know that they've got a lot
of work to do they know that there's a
lot of fans out there that aren't happy
with the MCU right now and I know
there's a lot of fans that are still
happy out there but Marvel studi still
wants to go back to everybody being
happy and everything they do being a
complete home run so right now one of
the problems that they have is we don't
really have an Iron Man of the MCU right
now I know somebody stated in a live
stream of mine the other day that Loki
is kind of the new Iron Man of the MCU
and I would have to agree kind of
because I don't know if you could really
say that somebody else is the main
person of the MCU right now maybe Doctor
Strange maybe Spider-Man but we haven't
seen much of him recently but as far as
importance goes I definitely think Loki
is probably the most important person
right now due to his involvement with
the TVA his involvement directly with
the Multiverse plus the TVA goes into
Deadpool 3 where we think we're going to
get that multiversal Avengers team which
goes into Secret Wars that is exactly
how Robert dowy Jr and Chris Evans are
going to return so Loki plays a very big
part however when you ask somebody who
is the main person it's really hard to
actually give an answer and that is
something that Marvel Studios kind of
considers a problem right now because it
was very definitive in the infinity Saga
you asked who the leader of the MCU was
you said Iron Man Captain America Thor
even as these other Heroes like Doctor
Strange came in and Spider-Man came in
and the Guardians of the Galaxy we loved
them all but we still knew at the heart
of it all were those three and of course
those were the three that would go on to
fight Thanos alone ultimately everybody
joined of course but they were at the
heart of the MCU right now now we don't
really have much heart it doesn't really
focus on one person and that's a good
thing and a bad thing but it looks like
Marvel Studios might be trying to change
that by bringing back Chris Evans and
Robert Downey Jr and possibly Scarlett
Johansson they'll come back for Secret
Wars they'll do a soft reboot and they
will remain in the main universe that we
proceed forward with for the MCU so
that's part two part one is the return
for Secret Wars part two is they will
remain for the next Saga of the MCU but
here's my question that I told you I was
going to ask do you think this will
actually fix the MCU don't get me wrong
I would love to see them back and I do
think it would enhance the MCU but I
still think at the core right now
honestly is bad writing I think that is
the core of it because one thing that's
really lacking right now is an emotional
connection to all of these characters
that we are seeing and I think
ultimately that comes down to the
writing Loki season 2 has amazing
writing and we care about Loki a lot yes
he's been around since Phase 1 but if
the writing for Loki season 2 was
terrible then people would be tearing it
apart right now as well it wouldn't be
that hard but having some characters
return that you could invest a lot of
your heart into that you could also
revolve the MCU around might be what the
MCU is missing right now and they could
essentially revive that by bringing back
these characters that we know and we
love but should they do that or should
we try to get invested in new characters
moving forward because if Robert Downey
Jr returns if Chris Evans returns which
it sounds like they are how long exactly
will they stay for are they going to
want to stick around another 10 years
they already retired their characters
are they going to come back and commit
to something that long coming back for
Avengers Secret Wars is a no-brainer
it's one movie and they probably won't
play a giant role in that movie but
probably show up for the end for a giant
fight but could they commit to doing
several more movies for the MCU if they
can kudos to them awesome we'd love to
see them return we definitely want them
for Secret Wars but go ahead and let us
know in the comments down below do you
think they should return and be main
characters moving forward in the next
Saga after a Secret Wars leave your
thoughts telling us what you think down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof